so twitch one last time
dance with me
more tributes continue to pour in for
Steven twitch boss after his passing
last week the latest comes from one of
his longtime colleagues former The Ellen
Show Producer Andy lassner he took to
Instagram sharing a photo of twitch and
a lengthy caption writing so many people
on social media are posting pictures of
themselves with twitch talking about
their close friendships with him talking
about the text they exchanged with him
just last week talking about the
conversation they once had with him the
thing is it's all true it's all real
those who knew him are not trying to
make this tragedy about themselves they
are just trying to convey to you who
twitch was and Andy said that twitch
made everyone feel like the most
important person in the world adding and
he did this for everybody not just the
people he needed or that were important
he did it for everybody it doesn't sound
real but it is all of it you really did
care for every single person who worked
at the show and everyone in his life and
the thing is if you met him just once
you felt that feeling that light that's
why I think you and I are hurting
because we all counted on him he was our
flame our joy our dancer twitch's mother
Connie paid tribute to her late son and
thanked all of his fans for their
support she took to Instagram stories
last Thursday writing family and friends
thank you for all the love prayers and
encouragement please know I see all the
messages texts posts and the calls I
can't use words right now please know I
will reach out when I can please
continue to keep us in prayer Stephen
Laurel your mother loved you to Eternity
and Beyond and new details have been
revealed about what twitch's 2023 was
going to look like according to people
twitch and his wife Allison had many
things in the works including multiple
shows brand deals and projects
pre-production for the upcoming year a
source tells the outlet quote he was so
excited about all of the projects He had
coming up and was very involved day to
day
foreign
[Music]